the jurgen experience do you know that
in the hunting world
um there's like a dispute between the
hunting world and the tactical world and
the gun enthusiast world
and they call the hunting world foods
yes
meaning and what's ironic
is the new warner brothers they cut out
the gun
there's a new remake of elmer fudd now
this is where it gets crazy folks
elmer fudd who's always been hunting
bugs bunny now he's hunting bugs bunny
with a scissors
which is so easy is [ __ ] it's the
you look at it and you're like even like
it literally made me go oh
[ __ ] like if elmer shoots bugs bunny
with a shotgun at least he dies quick
you're hacking away man and he's still
allowed to use dynamite they're still
using dynamite
so they're using explosives but they
can't use a firearm anymore i actually
did a video on it
did you yeah yeah one of the writers
basically said his justification for it
was you know
during the time when they were working
on an actual cartoon it happened
really close to the vegas shooting and
so they were like everyone in the media
wanted to stay away from guns so i'm
like but the scythe and explosions are
okay
look at this give me give me a let me
play some of this just take a look at it
can you but just have it in the
background just like i just want to see
what this looks like when he's running
around with a sight
oh there's something weird man about
redoing the past you know looney tunes
so this is a new version right this is
completely new
it's not like they took the gun out oh
my god this is
so so weird it's so sick
and he sticks a stick of dynamite in his
mouth
and he blows his [ __ ] face off that's
okay
i mean what is first of all what kind of
[ __ ] shitty dynamite i know right
that's the worst lesson you're teaching
kids no dynamite safety
because dynamite just makes your face
dirty for a second and then
and then it comes back to normal look
even his hat regenerates
like what the [ __ ] are we teaching kids
there's no consequences to dynamics
there is a gratuitous use of dynamite in
this one look at this
but look at that how crazy is the
dynamite blows his hat apart
but then it fixes it within a second
look at this boom and again boom and
again boom and again boom
this is a bit excessive but look he
lands oh finally his hat's [ __ ] up
will it stay [ __ ] up
let's see let's see it's [ __ ] up he's
dancing
oh he's got no hat boom then he gives
him a cake
with dynamite and it says coming soon
that is the dumbest [ __ ] i've ever seen
in my life
god that's so weird i think that would
have been 10 times better with a gun
but it doesn't make any sense no no it's
so weird but i
i'm not much of a conspiracy theorist
i'm not
sometimes i like i look at stuff like
that and i look at the decision behind
why they remove the firearm and i hear
you the whole vegas thing and
you know just the sensitivity to it but
i'm like but but your alternative was
just as
or if not more violent than than a gun
so my mind goes okay this is more of a
cultural thing
right i think i think there's an attempt
to be made to
erase the idea of firearm ownership in
this country because i think there are
large a lot
a lot of people like me like we grew up
even though i didn't grow up with
firearms
i still grew up with an understanding of
the second amendment i was i was taught
about the second amendment to a certain
degree in school
i guarantee you they're not teaching
about second amendment schools now no
that i can assure you no they
they yeah if anything i mean
there's definitely no positive message
no so
what it tells me is
i'm assuming the demographic of people
that are going to be watching that are
large
would be largely you and i who kind of
grew up with it in the past for the
nostalgia effect but then also a new
generation of kids are going to be
watching that as well
and we all grew up with elmer fred
having the the shotgun
yeah he's the hunter with the shotgun
and he's very quiet
i'm hunting rabbits but see here's the
funny thing about that you know
when it comes to the the issue of
firearms and we in the gun debate in
this country
by like you'll get people like joe biden
talking about you know all you need is a
shotgun you don't you don't need an
ar-15 shotgun shock who needs a ar-15
for hunting
yeah you casterize
elmer fudd and you take away his shotgun
what is that what is that saying well it
doesn't make any sense
[Applause]
you